ميتي انه نرجع يعني على بيوتنا ونتجمع مع
اولادنا ومع حبايبنا
يعني وان شاء الله يعني يكون بخير وسلامه
وكلهم يكونوا بخير وسلامه بلاقي مسكن من ه
السجعه اللي انا عايش فيها انا
وادي الاقي شربه ميه نظيفه الاقي الله
يعزك ابسط مقاومات الحياه فش حمام فش
الوضع هذا بطل عننا امنيات امنياتنا كلها
خلصت انه بس ادنا يطلعوا سلمين وخلص خلصنا
ير هيك ما بدناش ربنا يهدي البال ونروح
على غزنا بالسلامه ويكون عام جديد علينا
وعلى اهلنا في غزه وعلى الامه المسلمين
ونعيش هيك حياه سعيده وربنا يطمنا ويطمن
اهالينا ويطمن احبابنا ويرحم شهدائنا
ويشفي مرضانا ويشفي جرحانا وربنا يجيب فيه
الخير ان شاء الله انا روعه شجعيه لا قدري
واقفه وبدنا تنتهي الحرب شايفين الناس
والله ماتوا من السقعه اقسم بالله العظيم
ماتوا من السقعه واللي اذا ماموتو من
السقعه بموتوا من الجوع والوضع صعب يا عمي
بدنا نرجع على دورنا احنا بدنا نبوس ارض
البريج بدنا نبوس حطانها يا عمي مقسوفه
مقسوفه بدي احط خيمه هناك بس بدنا نرجع
بدنا نتهي الحرب
خلص 2024 الحرب تخلص وتق في المجازر وكل
واحد يرجع لبيت وعمار غزه والناس ترجع
لحمتها لبعض ونخلص على الحرب 2023 يعني
كانت صعبه علينا كثير وانت زي ما انت شايف
يعني كيف الوضع المجاعه احنا هنا في مجاعه
حقيقيه احنا هنا في الوكاله احنا مش
عارفيين نروح احنا بتمنى في 2024 زي ما
بتحتفل العالم كلها ويحتفلوا ب 2024 احنا
كفلسطينيين ه في مخيم جباليه بدنا نحتفل ز
زي الناس احنا بدنا يا عم نعيش بسلام احنا
بدنا نعيش بسلام زي ما كنا احنا بدنا
حمايه لاطفالنا لنسائنا
لبيوتنا يعني بيجي علينا العامل الجديد
واحنا مهجرين ومدمر ان شاء الله يا رب هيك
بتقف الحرب علينا وبتقف على اطفالنا احنا
شهداء قدمنا شهداء ابوي شهيد اولاد اختي
شهده ابن اختي شهيد وبنت اختي شهيده ربنا
يرفع الظلم والحصار والدمار اللي علينا
هذا وانه ربنا ان شاء الله يرجع اهالينا
من الجنوب سالمين وغانم ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله بتكون يا رب سنه على هال
المسلمين كويس وبخير والحرب يرتفع عنا
والحصار يرتفع عنا يا رب العالمين ويهد
بنا ويغير هالحال باحسن يا ام حا يا رب
امنيتي انه هذول العالم هذول يكونوا لهم
بيوت وحرام انهم يعني يظلوا هيك في
الشوارع وجاي علينا شتاء شتا يعني
جامد عام 2024 اننا نرجع على بيوتنا حتى
لو مكوم مكوم ابني خيمه واحط اولادي في
حضني واقعد انا وياهم ماهنا هنا قاعدين في
الخيام نقعد في بيوتنا على خيام بس كل
واحد في بيته في داره نتمنى ربنا انه يهدي
البال ونرجع على بيوتنا و ونشال عننا
هالغمه هذا وكف والله لحد هيك يعني
تبهدلنا اقسم بالذات تبهدلنا علي ال طربش
بنام بدون فراش وبنام بدون غطا وكل زي ما
انت ك اقسم بذات الله قاعدين بنيل بنولع
نار هي قدام عينيك اول حاجه بتمنى ان شاء
الله السنه الجديده
2024 الكل يروح على بيته سالم غانم ويوقف
اطلاق النار وبكفي مع اللي احنا بنعيش زي
ما انت شايف بكسر خشب بشحت عشان اجيب
لاولاد اللقمه قاعد بكفي معانه يعني بنات
مش شنطتين قاعدين في خيمه مش عارفين وين
نروح وين نيجي بدنا يعني يحل السلام
والطمانينه والامان يعني في غزه وفي يعني
في كل الوطن ان الناس تروع على دورها
وترجع ادورها تاني والشوارع تتعمر وهذا هو
رساله العالم يا عم انظر الشعب الفلسطيني
انظروا للشعب الغلبان مكفي شهداء مكفي
جرحه مكفي نسوانا تشردت شبابنا ماتت
اولادنا تشردوا تبهدلنا رسالتي ان العالم
ربنا يهدي البال ويشفي مرضانا ويرحم
شهدائنا ويفك اسرانا يا رب العالمين